a rapidly growing financial trend is
attempting to turn traditional banking
on its head it's called decentralized
finance or defy and it promises to bring
digital banking for cryptocurrencies to
the masses but with no middlemen and
almost no barriers to entry so in the
last 18 months this idea has really
mushroomed within the crypto market
estimates vary but a conservative one
says the total value locked in d5
reached 114 billion dollars in november
this year and while that's just a
fraction compared with traditional
banking d5 is growing quickly it has
increased more than 1200 percent since
june 2020.
here's why some are calling d5 the wild
west of finance where investors are
entering uncharted territory to take on
big risks for the chance of even bigger
rewards
when we talk about defy we're not
talking about a specific financial
product or service
defy is just the next iteration of this
this grand experiment in
cryptocurrencies which is basically just
to to recreate the financial system in a
digital online format paul vina has been
reporting on the equities market for
almost 25 years it has been covering
cryptocurrencies since 2013. anything
you could do at a bank or a brokerage is
handled rather than through an
individual and a corporation it's
handled through a computer program
you can think of the emergence of defy
like this
a dusty town in the wild american west
where there's no sheriff no bank and no
cash
here at the local trading post people
can trade and lend goods and do pretty
much anything else normally done at a
bank it isn't owned by a single person
or entity and unlike traditional finance
trades that happen here are verified out
in the open where everyone can see for
example one type of transaction that
takes place at the trading post is
lending to insure the trade the borrower
gives collateral for the loan the lender
then earns interest off this deal in the
same way a bank would
transactions like this are all recorded
on a public ledger that everyone can see
in the world of defy this ledger is
called a blockchain which is a network
of computers built to store and record
transactions
every computer on that network has an
identical copy of that ledger so that
all of the data is open all of it is
public this is different from a
traditional stock trade which works like
this
i have a broker the other party has a
broker the company has an institution
that keeps track of the stock itself all
these different middlemen all these
different intermediaries have their own
ledgers have their own internal
databases where they're recording the
transactions a blockchain takes care of
all of that and does it in an open way
that anybody can track the progress of
that trade
most defy services run on ethereum's
technology which also hosts the
cryptocurrency ether it's one of the
most commonly traded cryptos in d5 along
with stable coins digital assets which
are pegged to currencies like the dollar
the d5 services run on the blockchain
similar to how apps run on your phone
and the mechanism that allows them to
work is called a smart contract
smart contract is an idea i've been
around for years it's another app that
is focused on a bank-like service so all
it's really doing is taking all the
parameters of a trade and sticking them
into fields and automating it and then
monitoring it smart contracts are
designed to give defy transactions more
transparency and security and because
all the parameters are being inputted
into a program ostensibly it's more
secure because there there shouldn't be
any real debate or contradiction about
the terms of the service
despite this layer of security
decentralized finance carries a lot of
risk
in many cases the people facilitating d5
transactions are anonymous this has
caused fraud to become rampant
a poorly created smart contract could
have loopholes that allow scammers to
steal or other design flaws that affect
the value of assets
another risk is security and because
most defy services aren't insured if a
platform fails or is hacked millions of
dollars can be on the line the problem
is that
you may not know who wrote the program
you may not know how secure the program
itself is
that's a significant significant risk
that you really can't overlook
these d5 protocols
virtually once a week there is a problem
with one of them
so far this year investors have lost
about one and a half billion dollars to
defy attacks hacks and cons and in this
wild west of finance regulation is still
virtually non-existent though that could
change
here's the chairman of the securities
and exchange commission speaking with
the wall street journal about d5 but if
this field is going to have an ability
to move forward
it's it's going to be inside some public
policy framework
and inside some sort of regulatory
perimeter
look folks have already been hurt in
this field while decentralized finance
is risky many think the potential
benefits are worth it benefits are an
ability to make money
you are either lending out your
cryptocurrencies and you're getting
interest paid back on that and that
interest can be anywhere from five to
twenty percent even more you can be a
passive investor and earn money on an
asset that you were probably storing in
a wallet that was doing nothing the
other benefit is you can borrow against
your holdings a lot of these services
are being used as a way for people to
get a bigger pool of cryptocurrency to
go through bets out into the derivatives
market so it's a way for you to turbo
charge your cryptocurrency gambling
habit essentially
if defy continues growing it's likely
that regulations will be imposed to
smooth out its rough edges and reduce
risk for investors
which makes sense even in the wildest of
wild west towns a sheriff eventually
showed up to lay down the law
[Music]